Mariano Rivera set to join us we have
his former manager Joe Torre who will
join us in about 15 minutes
mou joins us congratulations on the
weekend where are you right now
I mean why plain my house oh nice
okay if I walked into your house will I
know what you did for a living
you what clear that agenda if I'm
walking into your house what I know what
you did for a living like how long would
it take before I realized that there was
a former baseball player who lived there
oh no you won't usually like you don't
realize that wait you want to be maybe
for you what maybe if you walk into the
basement you might see something maybe
do something on this guy Myers don't
watch it what would I see in the
basement what's the best piece of
memorabilia you have down there I love
the one piece that I have in my house is
the one piece that the Houston Astros
gave me number 42
big and older has right my whole event
you know all the world's here is my guys
my family that pizza I love how about
when you go to the bathroom like you
flush the toilet it plays Enter Sandman
do you have you thought about what
trying to put that down I was okay I
appreciate at least trying to do that I
don't know when you started thinking
about or dreaming about the Hall of Fame
but then you're there on the stage with
those Hall of Famers in that moment
wearing that jacket if you got the bus
there with you like how was that moment
and when did you start thinking you were
a Hall of Famer I never think about a
Hall of Famers who I finished my career
that I mean I was okay yeah I in my mind
I knew that I had a good shot but I you
know you always have to the way are
there with the way I always think you
know I said now you know if I happens
happens it's not it's okay with me I
mean I did my best but deep in my heart
I knew that on some that I had a good
good a good chance
and but my best thing was just when I
was sitting in in the room on Sunday
after the ceremony and I was sitting
with all those guys the one you play you
see yourself in played him or you wanted
to meet him you know hang out on and all
those guys man Sandy Koufax and when I
work there you're chit-chatting with
those guys and you know being one of
them amazing I mean your mind can't
comprehend that because it's all so
special why was sandy koufax so special
to you at least to meet I don't I don't
I was out of pictures you know you want
to roll those guys and as you want to
follow their steps in all sides Andy was
one of the greater pictures less than
the picture that I that are in here in
place for that many years so they may
have to do something special for him to
be only ten years and be the whole you
know something like that but I mean only
him I just mentioned it but uh everybody
everybody they were there you know Carew
I mean seven times batting champion you
don't see that too often you know
anything yeah it's just - yeah it's a
special special weekend and you know
just brings back so many memories for so
many people I was also curious when did
you go what was the day like or do you
remember when you were told that you're
not going to be a starter that you're
going to be a reliever you know I was an
attached to the role of the star starter
I was just I wanted to build a big list
so as long as I say in the big leagues I
was happy with her I mean I was okay he
didn't bother me at all you know I just
took my role I mean they put me the
local leave job I did that and they put
me in a terrible I did that and they put
me in the closest and I did that so to
me it was just a blessing that I was in
the big leagues why don't you think it
worked Alice's starter
why they work out yeah well the reason
is because I mean I have only God for
five innings and I was running empty
[Laughter]
till there are the best role for me was
where they could be because I was more
efficient and I had to throw less
pitches so I was better doing that
obviously and you know the rest is
history
he's Mariano Rivera the Hall of Famer
five-time World Series champ all-star 13
times Joe Torre is coming up in about
ten minutes from now what's your
favorite Joe Torre story oh man my
favorite Joe told you just I mean 96 I
came in in spring training and I wanted
to reduce myself and you know I start I
start I speaking to lengths to remain in
Spanish and when he look at me like I'm
crazy and I'm like you don't speak
Spanish huh he remains as mad no man I
mean I was so embarrassed and a few men
who mean coach you know you told me in
the eighth inning two hours inning if
they hit the ball to center field I will
catch it and then put me in the book
boom in the game to my dream and that's
so Joe never did Joe never put you in in
centerfield opened after open those
doors but he never put means in a few
what was that feeling like when you
either heard the music or when the doors
open for you to come in for the bullpen
what what which one was was the one that
the thing that clicked when the doors
were open okay when the doors were
opened my god I was something special I
was like you know time to zoom in locked
in and let's go in the human but you
no choice in that Enter Sandman song the
marketing people okay so the Yankees
picked that for you
if you would have picked your song your
your walk-up song what would you have
picked
well there's a song from a Panamanian
artist Ruben blades oh yeah the the song
is called patria party is our kind of
like place religion in in here for us is
something special as a Panamanian I will
use the Ruben blades also an actor as
well very talented actor oh yeah yeah
very very talented you what what else
we're gonna do with your life now oh
I've been working when we have a church
in Jerusalem in a hardy foundation
family obviously but with the foundation
we are we took a challenge to build a
learning center for those
underprivileged boys and girls that are
in need you know and my challenge is to
help as much I can to do that so me
that's that's what I wanted to do it you
know I love that and you know why not
you know I wanted to help as much as I
can like I say that's great great to
hear that if a red sock came to you moe
and said can you can you teach me your
pitch let's say Chris Sale saw you would
you help a red sock understand how to
throw your your pitch a lot of guys came
to me a lot of wrecks are non Red Sox
and I did try to teach my lip [ __ ] you
know oh okay is a blessing that you
receive is just yours I talked to a lot
of people I help a lot of people and
because I have records or no resource
you know exactly that's my DNA you know
what
I will not try to change something
because it's a reaction or not you know
I trying to help where I can
it's great to talk to you
congratulations does Jeter get 100% of
the vote when he's up mo I hope so Tomi
community you know Adam vote
I don't boat you know but to me is did
you ever face Jeter like spring training
or any any situations I'll remember
telling them yes I did I put the ball
over the place so you can hear anybody
else you're trying to run it in and
break this bat now heimo congratulations
a wonderful weekend and appreciate your
time thank you guys thank you god bless
thank you very much that's a Mariano
Rivera Hall of Famer five-time World
Series champ 13 time all-star for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]